All right, here's the story that I think a
lot of you will find interesting.
It's sort of an internal media and punditry
story.
Uh, Dave Ruben was confronted by a couple
of students actually during recent events.
One of the events were sponsored by the right
wing organization, turning point USA and a
student.
In this first video, we're going to look at,
turn to Dave Rubin and said, among other things,
why won't you interview or debate David Pakman?
Why won't you debate Sam Cedar or Natalie
when, but eventually it got to, why won't
you interview David Packman?
And if you're not familiar with Dave Ruben,
he's a cultural critic and Internet sensation
who opens the floor to the battle of ideas
by interviewing people, mostly conservative
people.
Uh, since he had a political awakening in
which he realized that he didn't leave the
left, but the left had let, uh, had left him.
Okay.
That, that's sort of a summary of a one version
of Dave Rubin.
Okay.
Anyway, I used to sort of be friends with
Dave Rubin and we would talk on the phone
privately.
I at one point had an open invite to do his
show, sort of like whenever I'm in Los Angeles.
I've tried to take him up on that.
Last time I was in la, it didn't work.
It hasn't happened for, for a variety of reasons.
And Sam Cedar from the majority report is
actually been trying to debate Dave.
I've been hoping more to just have a conversation
about ideas that I think are good ones and
that I can defend with facts.
Um, and he's not done any of these interviews.
Some say he's dodging others say he's simply
correct not to interview bad faith actors
like me I guess.
Or Sam Cedar, I dunno.
So a student confronts him at Santa Clara
University a few days ago.
Asked him about, about this.
Let's take a look at how it went.
Hey Dave.
Oh Man.
So I've been watching your programs.
This is about like early time in high school
and gone to college.
So it's been awhile.
But um, one thing that I really liked, something
that you talked about here was the difference
between a diversity of thought and a diversity
of identity.
Sure.
Now, but then with a diversity of thought
is I feel like that's a problem you actually
perpetuate on your show because the only time
you really have left when you guess are when
they're members of the intellectual dark bugs
that just carries her Weinstein and they're
only there for the bulk of the time to, uh,
talk about the regressive left.
And so I pretty much wanted to ask you, why
won't you have Sam or Sam Cedar on?
Yeah, it's recording here.
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean, the guy's just, he's just in dishonest
player who's just lied about me repeated.
But you're like, I'm not going to do so would
you be willing to have now when of contract
points or David Hochman or Calico and ski,
all of these other progressive's who in principle,
I'm not against having any of them, but I'm
not going to have people that attack me personally.
I think it's pretty obvious as you want your
idea up here, like I don't want to Jackie
will personally, I'm happy to talk about ideas
you're going to go have to me personally here.
You're a lie down on Saturday and things like
that.
Like it's just not the game on the line.
There's no winning.
I mean I have a certain set of rules when
it comes to talking to people and how I sort
of behave as a public person.
And if you don't have rules, like I'm just
not that interesting.
So we call Santa dishonest player.
He's asked about me and others and I guess
he says in this clip, he's not in principle
against it, but he's not going to interview
people who attack him personally or who lie
about them or who slander him.
And when I saw this, I thought he, he can't
be saying I'm attacking him personally.
Right.
Or, or that I'm lying about him.
I mean he, he knows me.
We used to text each other, talk on the phone.
He's no longer on the left and I'm on the
left, but he knows I'm a good faith actor.
Right.
Like I don't think he's including me in that.
And just a few days later at the University
of Delaware again, he's asked about me and
claims Pac man has lied about me multiple
times.
Take a listen to this.
The audio is not great but you can hear it.
Yeah.
All right.
Can I let Liz last one?
Cause I am a leftist.
All right.
Easy question.
Yes.
Is there anyone, I know you want to be the
same cedar in the majority of port.
Is there anyone on the progressive's uh, favorite
pacman or from counterpoints that you would
be willing to have a discussion with?
Anyone that will go after me for Pac man is
lying about me a bunch of times.
And I know you had him on the show once and
I get him on the show.
I mean, again, the lefties that I haven't
had that I've had on consistently where I
think are my good friends, if that's not left
enough for you,
Pac man is lied about me many times.
So this is super deceptive in a few ways.
I mean, first he says, Oh yeah, I did have
David Pakman on.
He didn't have me on his current show.
He had me on when he was still, I think it
was on aura TV.
I had done a piece critiquing Reza Oslon and
he had me on to talk about that.
It wasn't like his current show since there
has been, you know, a clamoring for more leftwing
guests.
But more importantly, tell me the lies I told.
Right.
If there's anything I can be fairly criticized
about when it comes to my relationship with
Ruben, it's that I've actually been to nice
and I've been to fair to him in a sense.
I've been asked to comment about him and to
be interviewed for multiple articles that
I thought might be hit pieces.
And I declined.
Just on that basis.
I specifically critique Ruben without attacking
him as an individual.
I have not said anything that I knew to be
false about Dave Rubin.
I might have an opinion that's wrong, right?
For example, I've said, uh, I don't get how
someone has a complete political awakening
at nearly 40 years of age where they go from
saying they basically like everything Bernie
Sanders is offering a few years ago to, uh,
you know, the, the kind of Ben Shapiro, et
Cetera, et Cetera, right wing.
I don't know how that's possible.
It's not an attack.
It's my opinion.
I'd love to talk to them about it and he can
explain to me how it is that he had such an
awakening.
He has my number.
The first time I supposedly told a lie about
him, if David texted me and said, Hey, pac
man, uh, x was ally, or that wasn't true or
I had misspoken, I would've immediately said,
I apologize.
I don't want to be spreading false claims
about people, uh, that are out there in the
world.
I stand corrected and I never would have repeated
that.
So called lie again.
It's never happened and now he says, I've
loud about lied about it multiple times and
he doesn't name one.
I also think by the way, that it's very hypocritical.
I hope he doesn't think this is an attack.
This is just a critique of what he's saying.
It's hypocritical to use this standard of
he won't interview people who make personal
attacks or are bad faith actors because he
does it all the time.
Right?
I mean, I'm not making a personal attack.
I'm saying he makes personal attacks.
Here's an example of something Dave has tweeted
out to a possible guest named Jack Smith.
He said, Hey Jack, you're an embarrassment
to journalism and that takes a lot these days.
Come on my show and I'll show you what a real
liberal is or better yet, you and Jordan Peterson
face to face, I'll pay for your flight hotel
and all the soy you can drink.
Not exactly the catalyst to acetyl exchange
for the betterment of human understanding.
Right?
Another example to Sarah Silverman, the comedian
who is politically on the left.
She had tweeted something about how racists
rarely think that they are racist.
And Reuben responded just like how entitled
Progressive celebs think everyone else's backwards
and stupid or na meaning she's backwards and
stupid.
But because she's a leftist, she doesn't even
realize that she's backwards and stupid.
So for Dave to pretend that he's an arbiter
of civility as a way to decide who gets on
his show is a joke.
And secondly, the idea that I wouldn't be
civil is ridiculous.
I've had civil discussions with white nationalist,
Richard Spencer, who believes that all all
Jews like me should go to another country.
I had a civil discussion with Jessie Lee Peterson
who opened the show by saying that the show
started late because he's black and black
people are regularly late and told me I am
a Beta male because I'm a progressive and
I still managed to have a civil conversation
with him.
So if anyone on the list that was given during
these questions by the students in the audience
could guarantee a civil discussion.
I would argue that it's me.
Maybe Dave's not pleased with how our interview
went the last time that we did an interview,
which was years ago.
I don't think he would agree to an interview
at this point.
Um, we'll be republishing that to Youtube
and Facebook at some point soon since a lot
of you didn't see it.
Uh, but this is this, I don't believe that
this is honest.
It's not a personal attack, Dave.
I'm saying I don't believe that you're being
honest.
I want to talk with you about what these lies
are and then we can adjudicate them.
Let's have the conversation.
I may actually be an la, uh, relatively soon
and I'll, I'll mention that if I'm going to
be, and maybe we can actually sit down and
have this conversation.